[Musica]
ultim'ora da una pandemia che di fatto
ha cambiato il paradigma della nostra
vita ha cambiato il modo con cui viviamo
e ha camminato forse la prospettiva che
abbiamo il futuro del futuro
trasformando di fatto la nostra vita
però questa trasformazione tutti gli
elementi questa formazione hanno già
presenti prima è semplicemente la
pandemia è stato quel vento che ha
accettato il cambiamento e che ci sta
portando verso una nuova realtà dal
progettista fra la domanda che mi pongo
è in quanto dello spumone di vivere
quindi come come come probabilmente
andrà a cambiare la nostra vita dove
stiamo andando
il primo del prima diciamo di questa
crisi di questa fase già credevo che ci
fossero diverse forze che stessero
quindi anno della nostra vita in
particolare tre dove però una di queste
oggi li dalla estremamente più
propositiva la prima era sicuramente la
tecnologia che grazie alla sua
meraviglia la sua magia la sua capace di
essere esponenziale stava già cambiando
il modo in cui vivevamo il modo in cui
venivamo il futuro
c'era poi una serie di fenomeni segnali
sia pratiche deboli legati alla cultura
ad esempio i fenomeni culturali caso
dalla citazione della sostenibilità alla
persona ambientale alla questione dei
diritti civili erano tutte forze in
parte subite in parte estremamente
evidenti che stavano in qualche modo
cambiando la nostra cultura generale
però credo che si aggiunta a questi due
elementi una terza forza che era era lì
era un po meno meno meno forte progresso
trovarsi è diventata estremamente
evidente ma qui l'aspettativa la voglia
di camminare
io penso che tutte le persono questo
parlando si aspettino che la vita due
anni non sia quella che viviamo oggi e
si sa comunque diversa da quella che
anno fa
c'è la gente sta aspettativa che il
mondo cambi che tutti dobbiamo deve
cambiare forse non noi stessi ma
contesto debba cambiare e credo che
questa questo nuovo di vivere barra
verso un nuovo tipo di comportamento che
negli ultimi mesi con i colleghi abbiamo
dei filo di continuità ibrida di abril
continuo che cosa ebbe il continuum come
un contesto in cui le persone si
aspettano di vivere esperienze in modo
completamente fluide simmetrico a fisico
digitale cibernetico quindi ci
aspettiamo di prende in futuro di poter
fare qualunque cosa se vogliamo nel
mondo fisico se mostriamo nel mondo
digitale se vogliamo delegandolo ad una
macchina che lo farà per noi alla
ricerca della totale libertà siede il
canale che nei luoghi del tempo
aspettative che in futuro possiamo fare
acquisti in un negozio anche notte
possiamo fare ogni giorno possiamo
parlare con una persona studi commerce
facendoci consigliare possiamo avere
nuovi scenari che mettono in modo molto
più fluido e molto più integrato il
contesti i servizi e prodotti che
andiamo utilizzare ma specialmente per
rispondere a quello che un cambio di
comportamenti di aspettativa
vale a dire vogliamo libertà vogliamo
libertà come persone come individui di
poter fare quello che vogliamo
quando vogliamo dove vogliamo nel tempo
che abbiamo e questo credo che sia la
forza più grande che che impatterà sul
mondo del lavoro che il mondo del
commercio che il mondo della vita
privata dei rapporti proprio perché è
una votazione è evidente che oggi è
possibile non è soltanto è totalmente
diventa probabile proprio grazie al co
vide proprio grazie a quello che il
fenomeno operativa che stiamo vivendo
però sempre regista mi emerge una nuova
domanda ma questa cosa si può vivere si
potrà vivere così sono nelle città o si
potrà vivere risposte che proprio
garanzia al contesto e tecnologia
potremmo viverla anche fuori nelle città
nonostante noi
sono cresciuti con i millenials in una
in una generazione che ha visto le città
come gli attori principali del
cambiamento dove avviene la gente
ficazione dove l'economia domina e non
sarà probabilmente così ancora in futuro
io credo che sinceramente che l'economia
resterà rientri fi car nelle grandi
città milano londra zurigo piuttosto che
parigi
però credo che le persone per quanto
lavoreranno per le città non sono più
sicuro che lavorano nelle città
naturalmente lavorano per le città in
modo diffuso stanno forse degli smart
citizen fuori delle smart cities ad
esempio immagino un futuro dove ci
saranno le persone a cui piace vivere i
chip arm che lavorano la casa altre
parole aggregarsi a socializzare nei
luoghi di lavoro e quindi si potranno
con gli altri
altre che invece cercano una vita
diversa dei borghi lavorano da remoto e
raggiunge 12 tasto quando necessario
quindi tante casistiche di immerse in
tante modalità diverse con temporali
diversi magari alcun lavora di giorno
con quell'ora di notte però tutto questo
semplicemente per rispondere a una nuova
spettati va nel fare bene che cosa vuol
dire essere vivere bene che poi ci
potrebbe portare anche al concert i più
evoluti i più avanzati quindi realizzare
un mondo nei servizi di sistemi di
prodotti per l'hiv continuum per
resistere non hanno liberato una
soltanto ripensare in modo cui son fatti
questi elementi richiederà proprio anche
di pensare come sono fatte le città sia
grandi che piccole che i contesti
enologica di smart cities diffusa dove
chiaramente le grandi città torino
potresti collegare all'esterno
attraverso che troppo al mese di cui
unica sui dati anche di logistiche di
mobilità avanzata perché dovremo trovare
il modo per primeggiare in modo smart
non soltanto le comunicazioni ma anche i
prodotti i beni e le persone in modo
completamente fluido o un modo
completamente dinamico in modo
completamente legato all'improvvisa
delle persone
io credo sinceramente in questo nuovo
modo di vivere ci porterà ad una
maggiore sostenibilità della vita sia in
termini personali perché permetterà
naturalmente un un equilibrio vita e
lavoro più vicino quello che è il tuo
circadiana le abitudini e la volontà dei
singoli sia in termini sociali perché ci
sarà comunque una dinamica di
sostenibilità per le comunità locali che
avranno probabilmente un nuovo un nuovo
rehavam ping economica perché la
richiesta distribuita ed evidentemente
ambientale perché se riusciamo a
limitare a limitare l'impatto ambientale
gli spostamenti degli effetti del nostro
vivere in modo oggi intricato
probabilmente riusciremo a tutelare in
modo molto migliore l'ambiente avremo
anche un interesse grande molto diffuso
a tutto l'ambiente in cui viviamo
quindi il mito messaggi lavorazione
organizzare un po tuoi prodotti servizi
e contesti che abbraccia questa
trasformazione
potremmo veramente che era un futuro più
sostenibile per tutti problema è una
domanda aperta che è stranamente diffide
con le cui stiamo parlando erano è un
nuovo comportamento che promuova visione
della società
ma la domanda è ma quanto la polis la
rappresentanza la parte diciamo se di
politica che di associazionismo che di
moral suation vorrà cambiare
abbracciando questa visione siamo
disposti a cambiare anche la nostra
società e le regole che darmi una
società per abbracciare questo desiderio
di vivere in un modo diverso
questa la domanda che ci dobbiamo porre
nei prossimi anni
[Musica]